why is no one giving me waves that's why
i'm angry right
thank you large trap very cool no wave
check today though
welcome back to meme review it's so
goddamn cold in here that it hurts to
clap my hands
but i hate that god damn it will elon
musk be hosting bonus meme this week
inconclusive ah we're just gonna have to
go to the last episode to find out
don't skip ahead you dingus if you skip
ahead he goes away
that's what everyone everyone knows that
my god
very on point with the theme today mars
rover latest fattest meme
f's in the chat i want to see some f's
in the chat because today
actually a couple days ago nasa will
officially have to say goodbye
to the little ruvver the opportunity
ruvver was meant to last just 90 days
and instead marched on for 14 years
it finally lost contact with earth after
it was hit by a fierce dust storm
last message sent last june my battery
is low and it's getting dark
[Music]
thank you for your service mars
opportunity mover
if that isn't the cutest goddamn thing
i've ever seen
that's the cutest thing i've seen in my
life
f's in the chat opportunity
opportunity you gotta get up
roses are red i don't feel so good mr
stark
my batteries are low and it's getting
dark
single tier wait this thing can talk i
don't understand this wait it sent the
message
that it's getting dark what is it some
a.i from 14 years ago
what is this rest in peace mars
opportunity ruler when you work for 15
years instead of just 90 days
it ain't much but it's honest work
arigato gozaimasu
mars roversan your service will never be
forgotten
you will never be forgotten until give
it a couple of weeks
nasa sends a ruvver out on a 90-day
mission to mars
opportunity 15 years later my time
has come it has come everyone
such as it will for everyone of course
but there has never been a tragedy
bigger than the mars rover disappeared
but
here's what i'm thinking he could still
be out there listen
wipe your tears there is still hope for
opportunity there is still opportunity
and hope for opportunity
there still are okay you know what
listen to this elon musk
is on it okay he's sending his finest
tesla cars over there to save the
opportunity roover i'd like to take the
opportunity to
press f to pay respect for our fallen
master over
hashtag thank zoppy the first city
created on mars should be named
opportunity he ain't dead
listen up you little kids reasons to
live if
elon gets us to mars we will see the
opportunity ruvver again
we'll find him elon musk flies to mars
to check up on curiosity rover elon
states
nah she's good fam she's good and i
installed a few mods
it's now a self-driving car you're
welcome
so i'm thinking here probably the solar
solar panels are covered by dust right
will it get buried by sand if we wait
too long like
the time is ticking here i want to know
like how can we find mars rover
when everyone talks about rover on mars
dying but you've left the solar system
to never come back
sadness beep oh yeah i don't remember
what it's called uh
it's been out for like voyager one yeah
of course
bye bye no one cares for you jerk we're
talking about mars rover here get
get back to fo okay nasa should send
another rover to mars
with a spare battery spare a battery
does anyone have a spare battery god
damn it so we could revive opportunity
and be friends i think elon is the man
for the job
and that's not because elon is hosting
meme review potentially this week let's
spin the wheel
well well well it seems like it's time
for next
meme the mars rover memes gets a 10 out
of 10.
just so mars rover will live forever you
are welcome everyone we have
great news not all bad news today
[Music]
anti-vaxxer kids are rebeling against
their parents
by vaccinating themselves so basically
after all the anti-vaccines people are
picking up gosh
i'm not actually vaccinated i should
probably go and vaccinate myself
now that i'm an adult i am so proud of
this community
memes are actually making a difference
in the world how about that
i swear in the future memes are just
gonna control everything you know what
what's the dumbest way we can do this
our moral code will be ruled by memes
our economic system
is already being overtaken by memes i
mean
it's inevitable at this point memes are
gonna take over the planet
next meme gonna cry gonna piss your
pants
maybe maybe income well then you
f ignore me maybe you should click on my
username on my profile
and you should see three dots to the
right of my username
click those three dots to open a drop
down menu
reads block click that option and
confirm that you want to block me
to avoid seeing my future post what a
god damn
savage sorry hamster son okay
i mean this meme is kind of not the
greatest but people did
their own version of it and it's just
damn those legs though
can someone explain this meme to me
gonna cry
piss your prince maybe maybe
all right you know what sometimes at
night i i wake up in cold sweat and i
think of
big chunks knuckles or whatever it's
called and i realize what a goddamn
awful mean that is
and then i think could it possibly any
worse
and here we are everyone here we are
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't know me god damn this meme is
a [ __ ] level tear
oh you're gonna cry piss your pants
maybe no i'm not
i'm not i don't piss my pants anymore
and i definitely don't think
all of the above please i have all of
them thank you
i'm gonna cry i'm gonna piss your pants
kermit
maybe come yeah maybe i will then maybe
i will then
unless you smash like on this video
right now i never seen the more
incentivized reason
to do anything in that debate next meme
this meme gets a two i don't know
it's gonna be gone tomorrow another meme
that is actually
i quite like and i'm not supposed to
give my opinion
but i do enjoy this man
[Music]
that's it that's literally it
from the eric andre show hey is that a
new meme
format new meme format
new meme format your life just became
two percent less miserable thanks to new
meme format
no bullying zone aqua let me add
hackers in movies
that's good i like that one 21 savage
america
kakeshi 69 in prison
oh was that your heart let me
oh that's so sad ads my ad blocker
fbi agent wanting some of that action
incognito mode centuries old diseases
vaccines girl scouts
boy scouts of america love it
i know this show is called meme review
and it's literally about me
giving my opinion but i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
i rate this seven seven seven it gets to
seven
do we have any more that's hilarious
[Music]
it's one luigi in smash
i hate this channel now
all right well i watched this let me in
montage
and i'm sorry i'm gonna have to rate it
at five now that was goddamn awful i'm
sorry
i'm sorry next meme god what are you
gonna do gonna cry
your pants maybe maybe i already messed
it up god damn it
next meme here's a meme that you've
probably seen already the aladdin memes
that's right everyone
the classic genie that we all love
played by will schmidt
that we all used to love and our god why
oh
[Music]
reveal of the new genie i mean who cares
honestly it's not like i'm gonna watch
the film
it's just funny to watch will smith keep
being part of memes
for the worst reason it's like a weird
crossover
meme from last month what should i wish
for i wish for
fortnite and marquez brownlee
he's back with a twist
oh come on don't mean my boy i miss eggs
oh god what is this
guys it's my new girlfriend
you look good oh god
pilatin oh disney i
i don't think disney can do that wait a
minute that's illegal
oh god no mercy holy heck guys they're
going
all out they don't even care about will
smith's feelings i bet will smith
like watching this crying he's crying
right now why can't he acknowledge their
memes
will smith are you listening hello can
we have a will smith
meme review we need people need to see
you laugh at this
it just needs to happen i'm sorry it's
the only redemption
thanos genie thanos genie
incredible more will smith remakes
just leaked everyone we have hellboy ah
shrek
ah homer samson will smith is just on a
killing spree right now
god damn man what a savage thanks
the genie is played by will smith so
aladdin
okay first okay pause one second pause
pause pause
pause everyone says last episode that i
pronounced aladdin wrong
it's aladdin right aladin is it aladdin
or aladdin
aladdin what edgar it's not aladdin it's
aladdin oh god now i'm confused
pics question mark what sort what sort
of pics usually gets sent
at 3am damn the sonic movie face reveal
damn i don't know will smith was going
to play somnick
or i like this one i'm not supposed to
say that i have two wishes left
me i wish the letter g was the letter p
instead
pini oh and your final wish me i wish
that
every e at the end of a word was an s
instead
penis
oh yes oh you don't like this meme
oh you don't like it what are you gonna
do maybe cry piece of your pants
maybe maybe and come is that what you're
going to do
now will elon musk host meme review gosh
darn it would be it would make my life
it would make this channel
after everything this channel has gone
through it would be the best thing that
it could possibly happen
it would save us from t series it would
redeem all evil
acts of this channel now elon sand spin
the wheel
i don't know what to say you guys don't
want to see me let's just go to elon i
don't know
hey welcome to meme review
with your hosts me justin roiland and
elon musk yeah welcome welcome welcome
um hi felix hey felix yeah we're going
to look at some memes right
yes and say things that are say funny
things about them i think we rate them
oh we rate them okay that's a review and
then
we're reviewing them out of ten of
course okay i mean there's some good
memes here
is this the first one i believe so okay
yeah uh a spoon is just a small bowl and
a stick used to eat from a larger bowl
he's earnestly presenting this
in congress and you can see you can see
how
how how easy it would be to just replace
that text and
add anything you want there it's almost
as though he wasn't saying that
so yeah i rate this uh out of what's the
scale one to ten yeah
is it one to ten oh uh i i have five i
guess
yeah six maybe maybe a six yeah is this
it's like a mid-range it's a mid-range
meme yeah i don't think this one's got
legs
also it's kind of tipping into the
political area which is like
who needs it you know if i get off my
lawn
[Laughter]
get off my lawn would be great
that would be really good get off my
lawn
okay yeah okay i'll i'll bump it up
another number because that's a good
so i give it a six year of my loan
mad a gas car and gas car
oh i see so you love you love madagascar
because it's just such a heartwarming
wonderful film
but then gas car you're like what i've
actually never seen this movie
you've never seen no i guess oh no it's
there's a lot of lemurs i refuse to
watch any movie with the word gas car in
it
that's not bad but no but i think i'll
make you everything is six
how do you but but how do you feel about
it is that trippy to like for real
there's a meme of with you in it are you
sort of like what the hell
yeah or have you gotten over that and
you're just like yeah yeah well i mean
this past couple years have been
particularly last year it was meme city
meme city yeah meme city uh that'd be
nice
a lot of memes okay now this is this is
a a proper quandary
okay okay okay would you step on stuart
little for 18 billion dollars
i love how poorly photoshopped it's like
it's like it's like they just
they got a gray color and just erased
whatever the hell it is like
just put him in yeah you kid the only
sentient mouse or is it sentient or
sentient
sentient sentient is it sentient
[Laughter]
that's not that's not post at all who is
that guy
that's me oh my god is that a weird
combination of you
and this is a real this is a is this a
real tweet no okay okay
okay okay okay man dude nothing you
can't believe
the idiot yeah this is where i'm face
smashed with uh
folks alone that's a funny meme that's a
funny one you could apply it not only to
you but to other celebrities and people
so yeah i i think that's a funny meme
because it could be it could be just
like a dumb drawing it could be anything
it could be so many wonderful things i
give this i say eight
yeah eight it's a solid eight whoa this
is this is so meta
me laughing at the idea of me laughing
at me
jesus christ yeah most people realize
that the
origin of the word meme is the i believe
1976 book by richard dawkins the selfish
gene uh in which he coined the
the word meme that uh ideas propagate
like
genes uh based on sort of like a
survival of the fittest paradigm only
the strongest memes survive
my wife left her purse on a chair and
now it won't stop telling me to bring it
han solo damn it looks a little bit like
jabba the hut
i mean i can't stop actually at first i
thought it was like a crab
and then i realized it was a purse and
then i realized it was a purse
uh it's kind of nutty how much that
looks like job of the hunt yeah i wonder
if the
purse company knew what they were doing
you know what i mean they're like we
know what we're doing
you know lucasfilm and disney is going
to have a
case on their hands with this purse did
you have the hot as the protagonist
yeah from his point of view why
uh he was owed money yeah who were all
these characters
[ __ ] with them leave it leave them
leave the guy alone he was just trying
to collect on some debts
yeah you know this this this purse
probably thinks
that it's right all right i give it i
give it a i give this one a three
three sure oh this is pretty great yeah
this is like
the queen have you seen this one i saw
it earlier today oh you did okay
be aware she can move in any direction
the queen is very powerful
i like that she's standing perfectly in
that black square
yeah and i it makes you think she's
gonna just only step in
step into squares like almost like
hubert she's with a bishop
oh she's with a bishop yes
so this is like a game of chess yes
essentially and notice he's also on a
black square he is
a queen and a bishop
and she can't just and she can move in
any direction okay yeah
okay oh it's pretty good i feel so dumb
that i didn't even i give this one a
nine
[Music]
oh my god dude
so [ __ ] dead jesus wait is that a
real picture i think it's a
real photo of a deer that probably
jumped into a pool and then just
thrashed around and drowned so that
is that true that's delightful um
you know what it's actually that
actually happened of course it happened
i think i think this is a reflection of
how
like just oh my god dark we've been
like a lot of weird forces at odds with
these why am i doing something
for not working oh oh here's a good one
here's a good one look
the cat ate the melon yeah and now it
looks like the cadet
now it looks like a watermelon now the
cat looks like a [ __ ] watermelon are
you kidding me good luck with all this
footage